こんにちははめ社長ですお正月早々こんな
動画になってすみませんえ今日2024年
の1月1日の16時の10時頃に石川県の
のが震源地の最大震度7のかなり大きな
地震がありました津波の注意が出ています
ので付近に住んでいる方そして日本海側に
住んでいる方はですね是非あのニュースと
か確実な情報を見てあの避難逃げて
ください高台に逃げるなり細かいことは僕
ちょっと分からないの言えないので
しっかりと確実な情報を正しい情報を持っ
ていると思われるニュースなど見極めて
自分の自分で考えて正しいニュース情報
だけを得て逃げてくださいでこれ今動画
撮ってるのが18時14分1月1日の18
時15分ぐらいなんですけども本の7分前
にもまた震度5弱の地震が野半島期であり
まして結構続きそうなのであの津波が去っ
たとかとりあえず大丈夫だと思わないよう
にしばらく続く可能性がありますので最初
の注意を払ってえしばらく生活して
ください情報とかかなり聞くように周りの
人に注意を促したりしてください石川県の
ので震度7マグニチュード7.6
めちゃくちゃ大きい地震ですねで僕今お
正月ちょっと後輩たちと旅行に来てて長野
県の北部長野県の北部の方の雪山の方に
いるんですけれどもかなり揺れましたで
ちょうどスノーボードしてるタイミング
だったのでタイミングが悪ければ本当に雪
なれにあって死ぬところだったと思います
なんか今日雪の状態とかたまたま地震が
揺れた瞬間雪山の頂上ちょうどリフト降り
て雪山の頂上にいたので助かりました瞬時
に一応動画撮っておきましたうわ
やば待ってやばいぞえこれ脱いた方がいい
すかあいいよ入っててもいいここにいて
はいうんやばわ途中じゃなくて良かっ
た多分リフト乗ってたらマジで危なかった
よねいやマジで結構揺れて危なかったと
思いますなリフトがめっちゃ揺れてて
リフト降りた後にリフト降りてちょっと
しってから地震がブワンってきててで山の
山頂ってのもあってすごい揺れてました
長野県の北部でこんだけ揺れてるので多分
市川県とか金沢とかのとの付近はもっと
かなり被害が出てると思いますがそこ周辺
の方はもちろんそして日本会側の皆さんも
引き続き津波が来る可能性がありますあの
注意していてくださいいやこれ
山頂じゃなかったらどうなってたんだろう
と思って結構怖かったですね今ちょうど冬
のシーズンでスノーボード今日もたくさん
のお客さんがいらっしゃいましたちょっと
ね自信があった時のある程度の対処方法は
分かってるんですけど雪山でスノボしてる
時に自信が来て雪なれが起きた時の対処法
とか俺全く知らなくて結構なんだろう命の
危機を感じたというかたまたまリフト最後
のお客さんだったっぽくてえっと俺と後輩
2人の3人でこうリフト上がってその後に
なんだろうレンジャーの人かなレスキュー
の人最後その遭難してる人とかなんか怪我
してる人とかいないかなって見回ってる人
がたまたま後ろにいたのであの待ってと今
降りると雪なれとかの可能性があるから1
回確認してから降りてくださいっていう
適切な指示的確な指示をいただいて安全に
下山することができたんですけれどももし
あれが山頂じゃなくてすごいあの勾配が急
なめちゃくちゃ鋭い山道とかを滑ってて
自信が起きてなれとかが起きたらちょっと
本当に何もしよがないなっていう感じで
かなり怖かったのでこの今冬のシーズン
雪山とかスノーボとかスキーされる方
たくさんいらっしゃると思うんですけども
ちょっと気をつけましょう俺はね多分場所
によっては何もできずに普通に雪なだれに
合ってたと思いますでもこれもう10分前
にさっき真の500もあったから本当に
まだ油断ならないんだよなそこでリフトも
全部止まってましたあとねすごい個人的に
思ったことなんですけどもSNSになんか
信憑性のない情報が非常に多いです本当か
かどうかも分からない正しいかどうかも
分からないような情報がすごい出回って
たりしてたのであんまりむやみに何でも
かんでもリツイートリポストしたりとか
なんか人に広めたりその情報に確証がない
限りは拡散しないようにした方がいい気が
します情報何でもかんでも回していいこと
ばっかりではありません確実適切な情報
だけを人に伝えるべきだと思うので例えば
俺はすぐにYahooニュースの地震速報
とか津波警報の記事を出したんですけど俺
は少なくともそういう確実な情報っぽいの
を選んでから共有するようにしてますただ
俺も焦るとどういう情報出すか分からない
ので確実なあのニュースサイトだったりと
かこれを信じろとは僕も言いきれないので
自分の目で見極めて正しい情報をしっかり
入れた上で状況に応じて逃げたりだとか
避難したりだとかをしっかりして
いただけると命の助かる可能性が少しでも
増えると思いますちょっと悲しいねお正月
早々こういうことになって本当は今日出し
たい動画があったんですけれどもちょっと
そういう状況ではないような気がしてい
ます普段取り出してもいいのかなと思った
んですけどもちょっとこういう自信が起き
た現場にいたのでたまたまこういう動画を
出させていただきました津波もかなり怖い
しやっぱ雪山のやばさこれちょっと盲点で
本当に怖かったので共有させていただき
ましたほのさっき震度7と別に震度5着の
地がほんのさっき起きてたのでえまだ気を
つけてくださいそして僕の実家も富山県な
んですけどもえ無事だったみたいですただ
かなり自信揺れが強くて物が倒れたりした
という話は聞きましたえ皆さんの無事を
祈ってますはい気をつけてください